who is the biggest music superstar of
all time elvis presley
jimi hendrix
or freddie mercury
some say it's this guy franz liszt a
pianist seriously a pianist
this great big story was made possible
by budapest spice of europe
[Music]
welcome to budapest hungary from this
city a star was born fran's list
he was a 19th century hungarian composer
world-renowned pianist conductor music
teacher and of course the first ever
music superstar and i'm going to prove
it to you
[Music]
i'm gay fosakosh and i'm an associate
professor of musicology here at the list
academy there were no superstars before
so so the very concept of superstar ness
was born with liszt and that's why i
think he was even bigger
a star than anyone today
in the 1800s listening to music was a
quiet buttoned up serious affair liszt
changed that
the audience behaved in a really
different way compared to anything
before
in music history ladies fell in love
with him just because of his piano
playing this was not only a an
entertainer he was someone to follow
someone to believe in so he became a
kind of a god there is this term coined
by heinrich heine the great
german poet listomania which which was
really true it was a it was a disease it
was
the whole of europe was infected by this
amazement of someone destroying pianos
yeah destroying pianos
that happened way before this
and it was also something that nobody
had seen before
[Applause]
[Music]
lee's
way of playing the piano was the object
of a lot of caricature he seemed to eat
the piano
[Music]
he moved and he he had really theatrical
gestures and he had long hair and he
knew how to use it to enhance the effect
yeah like this
if you would give me a time machine i
would decided to to stop by the
1840s and attend the concert of this
because honestly we cannot really
imagine them
[Music]
you